Melanie I'm so honored to be sitting and
sharing the stage with you I I couldn't
wait for today to have our conversation
joined with all these lovely women
there's so much to cover to be
at this experience to be celebrating the
power The Voice the ideas of women
there's also some really grappling and
gripping conversations that we have to
have
particularly around diversity this idea
of equity as well as inclusion and your
work even beyond your title has been
extremely
massive but we also have to look at what
the last few years has entailed and what
commitments have been made from
corporate entities and so I want to dive
in today with you this morning about
where we sort of
were and where we're going
but maybe let's start with this
commitment particularly that Google made
um right out of the gate particularly
when we think about 2020 um the murder
of George Floyd and the sort of
subsequent reckonings that our country
that the world has had and what that's
meant for your team for your
organization at large and how we're
starting to think a little bit
differently about the shifts that are
now
happening so it's a great question and
even before we get to like the horrific
murder of George Floyd you know I think
we need to step back a little bit
further and think about Co and the
comorbidities that were exacerbated you
know we thought about who was killed by
Co and I think that brought a spotlight
that exacerbated when we started to look
at um police brutality and you know
before George Floyd there was bana
Taylor Ahmad Arbury and this wasn't like
an episodic event it really led to a
global racial Equity movement and I
think Global here is important so my um
I have four generations in my household
my mom's 85 the youngest in my household
I'm a new GG to a granddaughter Noel and
my mom said who marched in the 1960s
with Dr Martin Luther King both of my
parents did she said I can't believe
that people outside of the United States
care about police brutality towards
black Americans I mean she was stunned
by this and so I think that backdrop is
important so what we did at at Google
like quickly
recognizing hey this isn't an series of
episodic events this is a movement and
we need to immediately deepen the work
that we're doing so we went on on a 100
day Sprint as a company like not just my
team which is a very representative team
I have a rockstar team that enables
everything that I do but this was a
company so we did a call to action
across globally across Google and our
goal was to really um ensure that we
were building sustainable Equity
internally and externally and so we had
teams that looked at all of our product
s and how do we use our products for
social good which is embedded in the
mission of Google to ensure that our
products are helpful and accessible and
then internally looking at we used our
black um leadership our black Executives
and our black googler Network which is
our ER employee Resource Group to look
at what do we need to do internally to
build equity and not just across the
black community but across
underrepresented minority so we look at
Black latinx Hispanic population as well
as indigenous Community out of that we
had eight commitments for external for
internal we've invested over $500
million in the racial Equity commitments
and they're they complete in 2025 so
we've learned a lot yeah along the way
and we do this work as a collective with
civil rights organizations human rights
organizations you know other
organizations
because you can't you can't do this work
in isolation this work we have to go
together what's been really first of all
that's really fascinating um and thank
you for really spilling that out for us
what's really interesting is there was
almost this new identity around what
discrimination what
marginalization um and even racism if we
can just call it by the the term that it
is um has inflicted on various groups
and it is sometimes a challenge to think
that it took a series of very
catastrophic events including um a a
tremendous Public Health crisis to get
to a place where our ears were open
right and even when I think about the
nature of the Partnerships that you all
have had particularly when it comes to
HBCU which you are a an Al proud Hampton
University hcu I heard there some HBCU
students I love all HBCU but particular
to so I'm not part of the club because I
did not attend HBCU but I I hope one day
to be an honorary member of Spellman I
should have been a Spellman woman all
right I see okay I'm sure Dr Gail is
beaming right now love to have I just
need a sweatshirt so meet me after meet
me
after but there's some unique
Partnerships that are expanding Beyond
just social justice initiatives and even
stepping into an area of Education yes
and very unique Partnerships
particularly around the future of work
which when we think about inequalities
when we talk about the racial wealth Gap
when we talk about who gets to build the
future who gets to imagine a future a
lot of times when we think about the
folks who are left out that is women
that is other marginalized folks of
color who don't necessarily get access
in the same way that some of our
counterparts do and there's a particular
emphasis on unique Partnerships um in
order to create upskill res skill or
even teach particular skill sets that
are going to be found in the future can
you speak to that a little bit more yes
and so um it's it's an
incredible observation and insight you
know our let's start with our
historically black colleges and
universities which are National
Treasures and we have to surround our
HBCU and Ensure that we continue the
pipeline and part of that yes is
investing in the pipeline for
development to make sure that we're
hiring but there's a bigger part to this
picture and so at Google I lead an HBCU
president's Council and one of the
things we're doing in addition to
creating opportunities for internships
and hiring is we are helping to amplify
research opportunities and so I'm not
sure if if you know this Charelle but
out of the HBCU landscape there are no
HBCU currently that are at R1 research
standing and that means that we have a
stewardship responsibility to ensure
that we're providing research
opportunities but research opportunities
also not they don't just provide
development they also provide diverse
voices diverse ideas diverse thoughts
into Cutting Edge re research and we
just launched um an applied Research
Institute a couple of weeks ago in
partnership with uncf and tmcf um
focused on HBCU with mathematical and
computational research to provide these
Hands-On opportunities and with Spelman
College through google.org we provided a
$5 million grant for a women of color
steam database this is no one else is
doing this and so Google developers
other HBCU are partnering hand inand
with Spellman to create this database
and this is the type of opportunity that
we have to continue to provide and just
you know one other example at Howard
University we have a partnership that we
just announced it's called project
Elevate black voices so how many of you
are familiar with automatic speech
technology and I don't know about you
sometimes I use it and it doesn't
recognize my voice and so Google's
research as well as external research
you know has determined and validate
that it doesn't universally recognize
all voices so Howard University will
hold hold the licensing rights but they
are doing that research to improve the
technology these are the types of
opportunities and unique Partnerships
that we have to have to not only build
the pipeline but to ensure that we have
diversity in the design in the products
and in the services that's um super
incredible particularly for students who
are currently at these institutions um
and are going to get access and
opportunity I think also to Google
Executives and employees as well who
provide mentorship and leadership as
well amongst these particular programs
and you talked about the Partnerships
with the United Negro College Fund the
third Good Marshall foundation and oddly
enough in 2020 and I always want to go
back to that date because there were
some really
interesting realities um people for the
first time were learning about all of
these organizations that were supporting
a and and have been doing work for
decades yes um so for a lot of folks it
was kind of a firsthand Discovery so
when I think about this area of De and
and sort of 2020 to 2021 we saw sort of
the largest growth of Chief diversity
officers being named for the first time
in corporate spaces we saw this kind of
deluge of focus on things like a 15%
pledge um across retail um or
representation on stages or even within
um authorship and books and then we hit
2022 and we saw this sort of decline
economically of course housing to
inflation into all of these things that
started to take precedence which also
meant the pullback of all of those big
promises those hyper focuses and the
shift was very pal palpable for for so
many of us um and we kind of knew that
it was going to come we knew that the
focus and the language and almost the
hysteria around how do we Elevate
marginalized voices might take a turn so
we sort of had to think about okay if
we're going to have this spotlight for
like 12 to 18 months like how do we like
rush out and get it done what's
fascinating is you talk about these
pillars these eight pillars and these
goals that are going to be accomplished
by 2025 which is absolutely fascinating
and so I want to get an understanding
of why has this
work stay the
course and where are we going because I
hear of these amazing initiatives and
opportunities I hear of the dedication
you're one of the few remaining Chief
diversity officers
unfortunately um that's really heading a
major company
um but I think that many of us might be
concerned about is this a is this a fat
are we going to have to change language
now we're only talking about ESG now
we're only talking about terms in a
certain kind of way because now all of
the language we learn in the last two
years is somehow deemed offensive so I'm
maybe you can paint a a picture of Hope
in some cases I was just thinking that
so let me let me interject with some
hope so what we're seeing today I don't
lose heart I do have hope I mean my
parents I told you marched in the 1960s
with Dr Martin Luther King and so we've
seen this in history before one of the
things that we've normalized that we're
not going to go back back from we talk
openly about race in the workplace I
mean if you think about um particularly
black and brown communities are either
hypervisible or invisible and in between
that it's a whole lot of stress and so
what we're talking about is how do we
normalize black and brown communities in
the context and that's what we've done
following the murder of George Floy I
think that's also why we've seen some of
the push back but we're not going to go
back to where we are are um I have a lot
of Hope with uh Gen X the way that you
know they have forced a demand for how
we interact what they want how they show
up and we're really leaning into that
and so I want to make sure that we don't
operate out of fear and that we don't
retreat that we stand strong and Google
is standing strong and Unapologetic
about the commitment we make and and
we're able to do that and I'm able to
sit in my role because we have an
incredible CEO with Sundar pasai who
really gets it understands it and it's a
company imperative so we have racial
Equity goals but we also have
companywide goals as well and our CEO
meets with our HBCU president's Council
um as well and Spins and pores time
there and so these are the types of
things that we have to hold on on to but
there're also the things that we have to
push for and to continue to demand
fairness and respect and dignity which
go hand inand with equity and diversity
and
inclusion and there's a lot of talk now
about belonging and I I think we should
like hit this head on I believe that
diversity equity and inclusion is
insufficient without belonging like
insufficient without recognizing that
everybody to like the science of
belonging says that people have to feel
rewarded seen recognized and valued in
order to feel like they belong and so I
think we see this added on and so these
are the types of competencies and
capabilities that are here to stay um
even though we get push back but push
back means there's progress happening
and the research shows that there's
progress happening yeah a little
discomfort is good for all of us right
little discomfort is good for the soul
anybody been
uncomfortable yeah all right yeah Ma
major growth Spurs happening around here
I I love I love how you talk about or
you brought in that that concept of
belonging um and also highlighted the
different requirements of generations um
I think you know I'm considered a
geriatric Millennial is anyone else here
a geriatric Millennial yes shout out yes
I'm Gen X so we're my Gen X people yes
kids of the 90s yes I mean y cuz we
remember before there was internet right
and yeah okay all right just just making
sure I have family in the room
here but I love that our generation
started to ask for more more balance
more recognition more sustainability
more Consciousness around how we show up
in the world and society as well as in
the planet and I think you referenced as
well Jen Z Jen Z asking for like J is
bold J shout
out I love it I love it maybe I will
help me put some stuff on Tik Tok later
today so just catch me backstage okay um
but there's but that belonging component
yes is almost a it's it's a force
multiple with Gen Z it is I'm going to
show up and be who enement it's not an
entitlement when I grew up you know my
parents raised me to to we're I'm first
generation my brother and I first
generation College I'm first generation
Corporate America and we were taught to
be better faster smarter but to compete
at average that never sat right with me
but I was taught to fit in not add in
Jen Z is saying here's where I add in
and this is what we have to do as
corporations and organizations it's not
about who fits into the culture it's
What's missing in the culture and who
adds in the culture yes that's an
amazing point and I love that you talked
about the belonging because it's less of
the quota of diversity right it's more
than just I'm a data point that
potentially represents something much
Brer than that it's much than that I
mean if and talking about culture ad
we've trained over 10,000 managers at
Google on how to interview for additive
skills not just fitting in because
that's a mindset shift and change
management that we have to do on our
side from a corporate America side to
ensure that we're taking full advantage
of this incredible Talent that's in the
world and so just as a closing um what
is your advice to other leaders that are
struggling to figure out how do we
create this new culture how do we still
prioritize what diversity looks like
what belonging looks like
um and continue to even just measure the
progress as we go along my advice is to
recognize what we're talking about are
Universal solutions that are common to
human to humanity but we have to
recognize that there are communities
within the universe that are situated
differently and require different
treatment to take full advantage this is
a basic right and a basic privilege and
if we could all as lead leaders stand
and take stock of that and lift as we
climb and ensure we're bringing
everybody along we will reach the
culture that we aspire to that's
incredible yes thank
you well we see why you are such an
amazing boss thank you we get to witness
it live this is incredible Melanie thank
you so much for joining us here on the
stage today at Ted women thank you for
everyone here as well and thank you to
the HBCU students who are also in the
room
representing excited thank you so much
thank you thanks
everyone